[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I first think with Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me Hank
and my brother John we answer your
questions give you two beasts advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon and I'm back
welcome back Hank how's fatherhood oh
it's good it's got its ups and it's
downs though I'll tell you that I I have
been told that there are difficult parts
of being a parent I had not been able to
internalize them now I have yeah it's
funny I mean it is truly something that
no one can prepare you for but also you
have to remember that lots of people who
are worse at this than you have done it
yeah yeah no that's that's definitely
true I don't necessarily want to base my
success on the worst of all parents but
I I think we are doing a great job and I
like him and he's I mean it's a good
thing he's so cute yeah that's fine I
feel like you're in some kind of like
heightened ecstatic state though like
you're talking about really finishing
your sentences you're just sort of
drifting off into the ether it's it's
interesting I'm excited to be back I'm
very excited to be back it's it's been
such a very strange time I left the
podcast and I left to focus on being a
dad before the election and and that
that it has been a a weird set of
moments since then and I yeah I'm glad
to have been away during that time yeah
because it has taken me a long time to
process and get to a get to a
comfortable place where I'm ready to
take on the world again well I'm very
glad that you're back and ready to take
on the world because I for one am
absolutely exhausted with having to be
both of us well speaking of having to be
both of us or not I wanted to start this
podcast off before your short poem by
telling people that they can come see us
both of us doing a live dear Hank and
John at nerd
nerdfighteria in Boston in February and
the dates of that event are February
25th and 26th he said as if he knew that
before he opened up the tab and his
browser to look
yeah and that's actually gonna be the
first time we've ever recorded a live
episode of dear Hank and John together
and for all I know it might be the last
time it it I can't imagine that it will
be the last time but I want to tell you
about some other people who are gonna be
at this event John George Watsky is
gonna be there Hannah Hart is gonna be
there yep big fan great on Cozart is
gonna be there great Laci green it's
gonna be great
my whole band wheezy waiter was gonna be
there Megan Tangis Michael Aranda
Michael Buckley Nathan said Nathan's
Ed's coming to nerdcon nerdfighteria yes
no no I want to go yeah so you can get
tickets to that at nerdcon dot-com right
Hank if you go to nerdcon nerdfighteria
com that'll be a slightly faster way to
get them but yes or just google it the
other thing that I would say though is
that if you don't live in or near Boston
and or can't make it to nerdcon durin
fight area in February you can also hang
out with Hank and me and probably a live
episode of dear Hank and John at VidCon
2017 tickets for the VidCon in Anaheim
California this summer are on sale this
summer this coming summer are on sale
now as our tickets for VidCon Europe and
VidCon Australia and I will have to be
both of us at VidCon Europe and VidCon
Australia because John won't be there so
I will know what it's like and I'm just
gonna do a dear Hank and John and I'm
gonna pretend to be both of us
maybe we can Skype you and maybe not I
don't know yeah we'll figure something
out last thing in the world of self
promo and I apologize for all the self
promo but you know we would like to see
as many of you as possible project for
awesome is still going on if you are
listening to this shortly after it was
uploaded and you can go to
projectforawesome.com slash donate right
now and get some great perks including a
recording of Hank reading the first two
chapters of the book that he's working
on a recording of me reading some new
writing of my own the first time that
I've had new writing to share in many
years and also an exclusive episode of
dear Hank and John just for people who
donated to the project for awesome so
please check that out at
projectforawesome.com slash donate I
hope it's been a good p4a I've certainly
stressed out about it
those people who are donating through to
get the dear Hank and John episode you
also we will be answering questions from
only the people who who got that perk so
your chances of getting your question
answered increase dramatically they do
not increase 200% and we apologize for
not being able to answer all of the
wonderful questions that we get how we
get so many good questions that we don't
answer I feel terrible about it very
difficult questions and funny questions
and all kinds of questions that that
we're not able to get to and we've got a
huge list of good ones right now but
first John we're gonna get to your poem
what do you have for me I've got a poem
from Mary Oliver because Hannah Hart in
our last episode and I were talking
about Mary Oliver and it reminded me of
this poem song of the builders it's not
that short I apologize but I do like it
on a summer morning I sat down on a
hillside to think about God a worthy
pastime near me I saw a single cricket
it was moving the grains of the hillside
this way in that way how great was its
energy how humble its effort let us hope
it will always be like this each of us
going on in our inexplicable ways
building the universe song of the
builders by Mary Oliver you know John I
got an email from someone who had tried
to email you and Hannah to let you know
that while this person really liked dear
Hank and John she really really wanted
to hear that Mary Oliver podcast that
you said you might do with Hannah mm-hmm
but she could only find my email address
so she just was telling me it all about
how she wanted a podcast that wasn't
mine so that's what I get for having a
public email address just people telling
me that they'd rather not listen to my
podcast and please if possible make a
different one that's not gonna have you
in it cuz cuz god knows would I not be
interesting on a Mary Oliver podcast you
got a question for me John I've got a
bunch of questions for you Hank but
let's start out with this one from
Seamus who writes Dear John and Hank
when I was born I had read
hair I mean is there a first sentence to
a question from a person named Seamus
that is more likely the red hair
naturally turned to brown when I was
about two years old well I'm glad to
hear that you didn't dye it at - now my
brown now my brown hair is naturally
darkening to almost black at what point
do I start to say my hair color is the
new color more importantly at what point
do I have to change the hair color
listed on my identification would it be
a crime if I listed my hair color as
brown for my whole life you're going to
jail Seamus now we know we've turned you
in we have your full name and email
address and the police are aware yeah
yeah Seamus I think you might be
catastrophizing just a little bit like I
think it's very unlikely depending on
where you live of course but I think
it's extremely unlikely that you'll go
to jail for reporting that your hair is
brown when it is in fact quote almost
black so this is this is a weird thing I
have noticed about my life so we've got
we're this duo
we got Hank and John Green we're a thing
and you have darker hair Johnny Hank
green we you have darker hair than me
but I have brown hair you have darker
brown hair but because we are a duo one
of us is the blond one and one of us is
the brown haired Roy and would you like
when you see us represented in graphical
formats I am drawn as blonde right but
if you look at my hair color it is brown
it is just not as brown as yours
so there's this very straight like
particularly in the spectrum of
brownness there is just a huge amount of
brown that it is almost unnecessary to
even talk about it there's basically two
hair colors there's various shades of
brown and there is red but even red is
kind of a shade of brown and also Hank
you know I'm looking at pictures of you
and I at least in the summertime you're
pretty blonde yeah it depends on how
much I go outside yeah my hair is I
don't think of myself as blonde I that
that is that is an unusual thought
I'm undergoing a change that is similar
to the change that Seamus is
experiencing only my hair is becoming
gray and I am wondering at what point do
I either say that my hair is gray on my
identification or ask my hair stylist to
color my hair which he has said he will
not do he said that that is a bad idea
but I don't know I don't feel like you
can have gray hair and be on YouTube I
feel like it's ha I'm having a little
bit of an identity crisis about becoming
middle-aged and being old and still
being on the internet and the internet
getting older than me I mean and the
internet being young and hip in a way
that I will never be again but maybe we
should just move on to the next question
that's probably a good idea this one's
from Lachlan who asks dear Hank and John
in the case of a world zombie apocalypse
what percent of the world would need to
be infected before everything is fair
game and you're allowed to steal weapons
and food etc obviously if one or two
people were infected regular laws would
still apply but what is the tipping
point so Hank before we get to this very
interesting question do you have a
zombie apocalypse strategy like is this
something that you think about because
of course it is something that I think
about well I have I have a short-term
apocalypse strategy it's not a zombie
apocalypse strategy but anything from
you know just a worldwide power grid
failure to volcano anything that's gonna
keep me in my house and stuck without
services for like a week or two I have
preparations for that which is just a
bunch of cans of beans and a bunch of
water and I got that in my basement I
don't actually have it in my basement
most of the cans of beans are actually
in my cupboard because I eat them
sometimes but I like to have a fair
stock of beans just in case
to survive unpleasantly for a couple of
weeks until things return to normal
beyond a couple of weeks I'm just a Tama
goner and I'm fine with that like
because I think that there's sort of a
law of diminishing returns in terms of
apocalypse strategies I think if you can
get through two weeks you're gonna be
good for like 98% of apocalypses and
those 2% it's a
long tail often to infinity of like when
services are gonna be restored if
services are never gonna be restored
like it's just not gonna happen for me
yeah I don't have those I don't have the
kinds of skills necessary I also don't
really want to live in that world like
I'm not I'm not looking to survive in a
dystopia I can barely handle our current
level of dystopia so like if things went
hard hard dystopian in the next few
years and there was a question about
whether you have enough cans of beans to
survive or or you know people were
paying tens of thousands of dollars for
canisters of water or trading in gold
teeth or whatever like I'm out I'm done
I'm not it's just it's not gonna be me
like I'll fight as long as I can I guess
for the safety of my kids but I also
know that I am NOT gonna be in that 1%
you know like I'm gonna be in the 99%
which is why my zombie apocalypse
strategy has always been the moment you
reach that tipping point and you realize
that this is gonna be a zombie
apocalypse situation with guns stealing
and no rules and all government's gonna
fall apart and we're gonna be you know
living in small tribes that are at war
with each other and can't trust or
they're a Walking Dead type situation
I'm done I'm out I like run headfirst
into the zombies right
well of course zombies aren't the actual
concern but but this is a thing that
people that scientists study you know
sort of in relation to riots or in war
when it's like when does it become
acceptable to start to start stealing to
start looting to start killing other
people because that's the thing that
does happen in the world and it is an
important thing to study and it a
terrible thing that happens and has
happened you know in in places where
there are nerdfighters and it sucks and
and and what it often comes down to is
it is the moment when people think that
it is become normal when they see some
some other people doing it that it
becomes like if other people are doing
it then I guess it's the right thing to
do
and we're very lucky to live in a very
stable society and I'm very very
committed to keeping it that way yeah I
mean yeah I think we should try really
I'm in I just want to summarize what you
said back to you so that you can hear
yourself you basically just said I think
we should try to avoid a zombie
apocalypse well I think that we should
try to avoid societal instability have I
talked do you think about how I believe
that stability is the most
underappreciated virtue I think you have
you have and like if I were gonna get a
tattoo like over my over my bellybutton
it would just say stability yeah well I
mean it's easy to say I love for I love
it when my life is stable and I am
absolutely terrified when my life is
unstable yeah and and we've got a
question coming up that we we might ask
about that very thing maybe I should
just ask it it's from Emma who who asked
your Hank adjoining seventeen and have
been with my girlfriend for about 11
months
I think I'm happy with my girlfriend but
I can't help but find myself crushing on
others a couple in particular who I
can't help being attracted to and I
found myself thinking about them a lot
is this normal
should I try and stop crushing on others
should I tell my girlfriend I can't help
but feel that I'm wasting my time for
experimenting and having fun by choosing
the less exciting but maybe safer option
having said that if I was to leave my
girlfriend for the mere possibility of
an exciting single life I think I would
become lonely pretty quickly
spaghetti and Katz Emma yeah this is a
tough one I don't feel like I can really
advise them on this issue I think
stability is great but I'm also a 39
year old arguably gray-haired individual
[Laughter]
not seventeen yeah I mean III think what
it comes down to is how you actually
feel how you feel connected to you know
the the other person in this equation of
course correct like you're always going
to crush on people you're gonna feel
attracted to other people forever that's
that's a normal thing but there is
something that I think is maybe a little
bit different about crushing where it's
like I
I'm fantasizing about being in a
relationship with this person not just
about like boy I like the way that their
mouth looks and and and and the
responsibility becomes to the
relationship and if you want the
relationship to be a thing and and
aren't just not just because you're like
afraid of being lonely but because you
like this person and respect them and
want to treat them well then then you do
sort of have a responsibility curtail
your fantasizing about being in
relationships with other people and I
think that that's I think that but like
of course like you know like having
those having those feelings is totally
appropriate you probably should not be
like hey girlfriend I just wanted you to
know that I've been fantasizing about
being in relationships with other people
that's not a necessary thing that you
have to do it's a thing that happens but
but deciding whether or not you're gonna
break it off so that you can have a more
exciting time for experimentation that's
that's up to you and it's up to how you
feel like you want to respect your
significant other and how you want to
respect the relationship that you're in
I think that was good advice and I also
I just have no idea how to be seventeen
the more I it's just an it's an
astonishingly difficult thing to be
young because you're living with the
size of the options are so limitless
like the possible futures in front of
you are incalculably vast and that's
exciting in a lot of ways I think that's
what's so thrilling about adolescence
but it's also absolutely terrifying or
at least it was for me it's kind of
paralyzing to think like well I could do
this and then I'm gonna be stuck on that
path for the rest of my life more I
could do this and then I'll be stuck on
the that path for the rest of my life
and that that feeling of like oh you
know like these two roads diverging in a
yellow wood in the famous Robert Frost
poem but the thing is in actual like in
my actual experience of being a teenager
the two roads diverged in a yellow wood
you walk for five feet and then the road
diverges again and then you walk for
five feet in the road diverged
again and so on seemingly forever and so
when you reach a period of stability
where you're happy with the road that
you're on and it also isn't splitting
constantly threatening you with whatever
might befall you I find that to be a
very pleasant part of life
I think adulthood in general is like
massively underrated yeah it's it's I
think less interesting to to write about
in stories these moments of like yeah of
just pleasurable sitting by the fire
drinking your cognac or whatever it is
that you like to do I don't I don't do a
third of those things but but it is it
is really wonderful and and I think that
our anxiety about getting to that place
is really misplaced because because
people think like oh I don't want it all
to end and I'm just gonna like be going
through the motions that everyone else
goes through but there's a reason why
people do that there's a reason why
people sort of settle in and and like
and have a family and like you know get
really involved with their work it's
because there's there's so much reward
right and it's it can be hard to convey
the you know the pleasures of that
simple stability yes it makes for bad
movies but good living in my experience
our next question comes from Michele
Hank who writes dear John and Hank I
recently went to make an appointment
with the doctor I've been seeing my
entire life in order to get my ear
cleared out it's been blocked with wax
and impeding my hearing for two weeks
now in going to make an appointment I
found out that my doctor has retired how
does one go about finding a new doctor
I've never had to do this before and I
have no idea where to start any dubious
advice is appreciated as I would like to
get my ear cleaned out in the future
pumpkins and penguins Michele I haven't
had a doctor
I mean maybe since since high school is
that is it I don't know if it what I
don't know if it's no it did most adults
have like a doctor that is just their
doctor doctor I have that doctor for my
butt problems but I don't have it for
like my whole body like I don't have
like a general practitioner you see on a
fairly regular basis when you have
health problem no and I have health
problems either go see my butt doc
because most most the problems are
related to by : or I or I go to them
like the walk-in clinic and pay my 60
bucks Wow
I mean I can really empathize with
Michelle in this situation because I
have retired three three physicians in
just the last 10 years like they've
they've they've have opted out they've
been like okay I've had enough that some
of them some of my patients I'm not
gonna say who but some of my patients
have pushed me out of the medical
profession yeah so the first one was a
great doctor he was my doctor for our
first five years in Indianapolis I felt
very close to him we had a wonderful
working relationship and and then he
retired but he was 65 that's that's
reasonable the second doctor that I
retired retired just two years after I
started seeing him at the age of 48
perfectly healthy guy just decided that
he had to get out of the doctoring
business right around the time that I
was recovering from my viral meningitis
then I had a great doc a really
wonderful doctor he wasn't conveniently
located to my home but I just I really
was a big fan of my doctor and he just
retired six months ago and it was
devastating like I was like the first
time I saw him I actually said to him
listen so you know I have retired two
doctors in five years are you planning
to retire any time soon and he was like
no I love my work I'm young I'll be
doing it forever four years later
retired hmm well then you should
probably go my route and see whoever
happens to be at the walk-in clinic that
day and I would suggest that to Michelle
in the meantime while you're trying to
find a new no no no no no this is not
permanently not permanently but like
she's trying to find a new GP but she's
got impacted earwax and she can't hear
and it's causing her anxiety so she go
to the walk-in clinic and get her ear
irrigated which is the most common
procedure they do with walk-in clinics
and I know this because I didn't afford
to get your irrigated at the walk-in
clinic you should absolutely do that
Michelle but the larger question is are
there health benefits to having
consistent care from one primary care
physician and the answer is
overwhelmingly yes that person actually
doesn't always have to be an MD it could
be a nurse practitioner
or but but there is there are definitely
benefits to having a consistent
relationship with one primary care
physician or MP or whatever also Hank
and I do not
never trust our advice our advice is
always dubious but like maybe especially
don't trust Hanks medical advice since
like I am familiar with Hanks medical
education and it includes one semester
of organic chemistry that was the last
time Hank was exposed in any way to
human medicine I at least have spent my
entire adult hood googling symptoms so I
am fairly familiar with a lot of health
problems but even even my medical advice
should never be trusted consult your
physician as for how you find a
physician talk to your friends and
family members about physicians they
trust if they have great general
practitioners or family medicine doctors
or nurse practitioners they love working
with and then also you got a look on
your insurance list to make sure that
they're covered by your insurance and
then you can find out where they went to
college which doesn't matter of course
it doesn't matter that much although it
matters a little bit to me because I'm I
am a I'm a doc I am a doc I am a doctor
snob okay I will admit that I am a
doctor snob I'm very happy with my
current primary care physician who's a
big fan of the pod so it's great to I
hope that you're enjoying this episode
doctor I'm not gonna say your name just
because I don't want a bunch of people
go into you all the sudden and you not
having as much time for me but a big fan
and you're doing a great job and I
appreciate it and I'm sorry that I
dispense medical advice on this podcast
never dispense medical advice on a
podcast and don't retire doctor whatever
don't he's honored we had a long talk
before I officially hired him as my
general practitioner that I was in this
for decades and I needed him to be in it
for decades too I also just want to
finish this question by saying that once
upon a time I got my ear wax cleaned out
and I made a vlog for this video about
it and I did it at the walk-in clinic
and you can watch that on youtube.com
slash vlogbrothers if you google around
enough I'm sure you could find that big
lumpy earwax coming out of my ear it was
an amazing experience I mean that's just
terrible self-promotion I think is great
I think I'm so good at the self promo
job nobody nobody nobody nobody wants
that like stop listening to the podcast
pull over on
side of the road pull out their phones
do it google vlogbrothers earwax and
watch that video right now if you're
gonna do that many steps could you guys
do me a favor and register for nerdcon
nerdfighteria instead of going and
watching see your wax video I'll put
another foot of the patreon this
question is from Scott uh and it's for
me so I'm just gonna read it as this has
dear Hank and John but but really just
Hank while discussing the Martian
terrain with some friends I refer to the
ground as Earth one very astronomically
knowledgeable friend said that I was
wrong and suggested that the earth is a
term for soil on earth than Mars we
should call the soil Mars was I wrong to
say earth still developing my
catchphrase Scott that's good you know I
like that Scott knows that he's in a
period of growth right now where he
doesn't have a catchphrase yet but he
also knows that that catchphrase is
coming right right do you want to think
of some catchphrases for Scott or do you
just want to answer the question sure
Mars no yeah you answered the question
while I think of some catchphrases for
Scott and then I'll just kind of work
them out as I think of okay well this is
an interesting question in fact the word
beamed up by Scott the word for Earth
started out as meeting dirt and soil and
stuff and then it got expanded when we
realized we were on a planet to refer to
the whole planet which is especially
interesting because it means that I'm
just keep thinking you're gonna
interrupt me but you haven't it's making
me real nervous great comma Scott it
means that the earth we chose to call it
Earth but we could have very easily
called it dirt or soil or or just you
know rubble or something some other
thing clay but we chose to call it earth
which is good because I'm glad that it
I'm not like a dirt or I'm glad I don't
live on dirt but on Mars this so that
you could still call the ground there
Earth but you should not call it soil
because it's not soil because soil has a
bunch of other stuff in it including
microorganisms and you probably couldn't
even call it dirt you might have to call
it Riegel if or regolith because it's
because it's
dead lifeless organic or non-organic
material every land I live in is
Scotland good well done John I'm real
proud of you this question comes from
Joshua who writes Dear John and Hank why
is it often difficult to breathe and
fart at the same time I often find this
to be an issue when trying to surprise
others with my farting Joshua come on
man you got it you gotta reassess your
life choices
you're either you're seven or you need
to I think sophisticate up now you're a
little bit gonna completely disagree me
holding my breath and they know that I'm
about to squeeze out of sorry I had to
question the rest of it we're done so
Hank why do you hold your breath while
you while you're farting first I want to
say that often times the dear naked John
we have to edit people's questions down
substantially so that it's sort of
easier to get get through them and we
read poorly the whole thing I did not
have to edit Joshua's question it is it
is just those two sentences they didn't
even say thank you or you know Josh at
the end that was it and boy I've got a
good catchphrase for Joshua oh yeah
Joshua good well Joshua Josh Joshua
you're just playing it safe because
there's a possibility that you're a
mouth farter and this is a condition
that some people have where if they fart
with their mouths open while breathing
and and don't close off their trachea
they'll fart out both ends at once and
you don't want to fart at your mouth
nobody nice you're making this up right
yes of course man oh my god
[Laughter]
I never know enough about science to
know for sure when you're making
something up but that is a huge relief I
was actually in the middle of Google
the phrase bounce water which by the way
whoa
regret hit the back button I'd never go
back do not do not do not guys do not do
do not make the mistake that I just made
do never if I can give you one piece of
advice it's never do that Hank we have
to leave this question behind and move
on to another question quickly we have
to go this is over the question is over
the new question comes from Annie she
writes dear John and Hank this summer
I'm going to be moving across the
country country to Jasper Alberta for a
job pause Annie please please let please
please please let me in to Canada please
just let me in to Canada I have some
immigration issues because I was denied
entrance to Canada in 1994 due to
insufficient funds and I now every time
I tried to get into Canada I'm put in
the line for the naughty people where we
have to get special interviewing and I I
just I need to be let into Canada but
not for a little while Annie but forever
also could you make it like 30 degrees
warmer on average in Jasper Alberta okay
I'm moving across the country to Jasper
Alberta for a job guiding trails on
horseback this will be my second summer
doing this it just so happens that
Jasper is in the mountains and I fell in
love with one of the local mountains
pyramid mountain
I don't know if Annie means that she
fell in love the way they fall in love
with a person or if she means that she
fell in love the way that you generally
fall in love with the mountain but we're
not here to judge her I'm planning on
hiking to the summit this is where my
dilemma is I'm very excited and I want
to tell my mom but I know she would be
worried about me going on a potentially
overnight hike on my own I am in the
need of some serious dubious advice
should I tell my mother about my plan to
climb this mountain and risk the fact
that she will try to talk me out of it
and potentially give her undue stress
and have her be mad at me while I'm
across the country or should I wait
until after I've done it and tell her
how great it was retrospectively I need
to know how old annie is maybe maybe I
don't she's growing across the country
to work all summer
guiding trails on horseback so she's not
9 that's I mean I don't know maybe the
child labor laws are different in Canada
but I'd be surprised if she's 9 I I
don't know
I don't know you got a kind of you gonna
judge your relationship with your mom
and you gotta judge your mom's mom eNOS
but it's not that big of a deal I think
you got to tell your mom that you're
gonna climb this mountain
I mean Annie explains later in this
email that it's a 12-hour hike so
theoretically it might not even come
overnight hike as long as you're well
prepared I think you just need to be
very well prepared Annie and to know
what you're doing if you are not an
experienced obviously don't trust Hank
and i's advice over actual experienced
campers but if you're not an experienced
camper that's not something I would take
on by myself but but yeah I think you've
got to make the right decision for you
and make sure that you bring plenty of
water and food and a compass and a fully
charged phone maybe a satellite phone
just in case you get super lost and like
a GPS beacon that you can like rip off
and then they'll find you no matter what
and players
you should bring flowers I am more
experienced camper than John that's not
true well you you were talk a bunch of
nonsense so there's that but I will say
that it's first definitely have someone
know that you're going even if it's you
know doesn't feel your mom but somebody
needs to control you're going that is
the biggest mistake that leads to death
in back country hiking is you go off and
people don't know where you are because
if something goes wrong they don't know
where to look for you but the the way to
make it much safer is to go with someone
else and and I know that there is a lot
of wonderfulness that can come out of
going by yourself but if if you want to
like alleviate some of your mom's dress
you can you could maybe find somebody to
do it with and that that maybe your mom
maybe go with your mom you know you know
2700 meter elevation Mountain I don't
know if Annie's mom's up to that but I
that that if I was your mom it would
make me a lot less nervous if you went
with somebody else and and maybe that
would make it easier for you to tell
your mom you would not bring a flare on
this trip no I wouldn't have bring a
flare on that trip I would definitely
bring bear spray though
that's Alberta and they got the Bears
there Oh God oh my god
my days of sleeping on the ground with
bear spray on my person at all times are
over
that's that's no I'm not I'm not coming
back to that place okay but anyway Hank
Annie's question reminded me that our
podcast today is of course brought to
you by mount pyramid now pyramid hmm a
pyramid that is also a mountain that a
woman named Annie is in love with and
that's okay nikola tesla was in love
with pigeons this podcast is also
brought to you by two weeks worth of
beans two weeks worth of beans available
at costco and will get you through
ninety nine point one percent of all
apocalypsis for the record nikola tesla
was only in love with one one pigeon it
was a particular pigeon and today's
podcast is also brought to you by gray
hair gray hair coming soon to youtube
there's other youtubers with gray hair
john you're just classing up the joint
it's fine it's fine it is podcast is
also finally brought to you of course by
mouth farters anonymous the place where
you can go for all four of your you know
discussions you want to have about your
condition of being a mouth farter which
is totally alright and nothing to be
ashamed of Hank let's answer it one more
question before we get to the
astonishing historic amazing
unprecedented news from AFC Wimbledon
and the presumably incredibly exciting
news from Mars as well okay well I I'm
looking forward to doing that
and and maybe giving you a tiny bit of
advice after having heard a couple of
episodes of dear Hank and John without
me about your presentation style when it
comes to AFC Wimbledon but first I want
to ask you this question from Justine
who asks dear Hank and John my roommates
and I have each picked out our favorite
holiday movies to watch together in the
weeks leading up to Christmas but to my
dismay one of my roommates picked
diehard which I am convinced is not a
Christmas movie it takes place during
Christmas but it hardly has the joyous
holiday theme that I would normally
expect from a Christmas movie I think
the plot could easily take place at any
time during the year my roommates
I'll disagree with me so I'll leave it
to you is die hard really a Christmas
movie well this happens to be as you
know Hank one of my areas of expertise
because I have spent more time watching
and thinking about the die hard
franchise than probably anyone on earth
not named Bruce Willis
[Laughter]
I feel like Bruce Willis probably
doesn't spend that much time thinking
about die hard actually he might it
might be right actually now that I think
about it die hard is a Christmas movie
for precisely the reasons that Justine
cites for it not being a Christmas movie
which is that it is all about the
holiday spirit it is all about learning
to be grateful for family yeah learning
that you know even in extremely
complicated situations love conquers all
and also never take off your shoes yes
never take off never take off your shoes
if there is an imminent threat of a
terrorist attack on the skyscraper where
you are the only chance of stopping that
attack I also have to say while we're
talking about Christmas movies and the
greatest Christmas movie of all time
die hard - die harder is also a
Christmas movie right it could have
takes place on Christmas Eve in
Washington DC a year after the events of
die hard 1 and the best part about die
hard 2 is that they try to make sense of
this coincidence by having Bruce Willis
over and over again and say I can't
believe this stuff keeps happening to me
on Christmas well I mean I think it's
quite actually it's it's pretty great
like there's a lot of interesting great
things about die hard but I think it's
pretty great that they have that the
Christmas theme stretches through the
whole movie
like it's you know it's a holiday party
at the beginning and when he kills that
guy and steals this machine gun he like
writes on his shirt and blood now I have
a machine gun oh ho ho because he had a
lot of blood - right right exactly it is
a Christmas movie and I think there's
something interesting about die hard as
a Christmas movie which is a thing
that's happened where people are like
it's it's kind of a rebellion against
the idea of
Christmas movie which is something I
don't love because they're like I really
like Christmas and like coming together
and experiencing a thing culturally even
if we don't all agree on you know other
things but like there's something about
the holiday time
everybody has their celebration it
doesn't of course have to be Christmas
but but they're like the this
togetherness and the family and that
like whether it's like you can't take it
with you or it's elf there's good
feeling Christmas movies and there's a
cynicism that comes along with being
like well I don't like any of those
where's the Christmas movie about dying
and killing people and blood and cocaine
right no it's definitely it's definitely
sort of a cynical response to Christmas
movies along the lines of a bad Santa
too or to a lesser extent Bad Santa I
mean I definitely get that I also want
to say for the record Hank that not
everybody celebrates holidays in the
winter that you know like it isn't the
holiday season for everyone but but yeah
I like die hard as a movie a lot I like
it less as a Christmas movie but I still
like it as a Christmas movie and I
support its inclusion if people want to
be cynical about Christmas it's a better
way of being cynical about Christmas
that bad Santa - Hank okay okay Hank now
tell me what I'm doing wrong with my AFC
Wimbledon coverage please thank you for
giving me the opportunity we all know
the story of AFC wimbledon there are
gonna be some people who don't but
they're gonna pick up on it you don't
have to go through the whole thing every
time we are with you we are excited
about AFC wimbledon but the moment that
you have you start this like long story
of how AFC wimbledon happened every time
that happened while i was listening to
the pod I had to skip it I'll be honest
with you if you could find a really fast
abbreviated way of doing it that would
be fine but just tell me what happened
in the second round of the FA Cup what's
that what is the FA Cup and what is the
second round oh I apologize I thought I
wasn't supposed to give any background
no different background new background
new context is great we're aware of a
life see what had happened about the FA
Cup is a competition in England it's
basically like a knockout competition in
which all the teams in England can play
each other and then like the big team
like Manchester United in Chelsea come
in in the third round okay so
everybody's gunning for that third round
ticket because then you can play
potentially a big team that's how AFC
Wimbledon played Liverpool a few years
ago so this was a second round FA Cup
tie against kurz and Ashton it was a
huge game for them because they're way
down in the sixth tier of English soccer
and they got off to a roaring start with
a former Liverpool youth prospect
scoring three goals Hank got two goals
in the first half and then completed his
hat-trick in the 60th minute and things
were looking very very bad for AFC
Wimbledon in the 80th minute down three
nil away from home to kurzon Ashton
everybody including me like I was still
watching it because it was the game was
televised which was incredibly exciting
so I was still enjoying just the
prospect of watching this team I loved
on television but at no point did I
think that they had a chance to win even
though they were dominating possession
but they were three nil down and then in
the 80th minute the 80th minute with 10
minutes to go in the game off of a
corner kick a goal a goal who scored it
you can't even really tell because it
was such a scrum hahaha
pretty amazing and then it was 3-1 in
the 80th minute and I was like well
that's nice that there was a nice little
comeback there and there's something to
build on for the future got this big
game coming up on December 10th against
the franchise currently playing in
Milton Keynes and then Tom Polian scored
a goal a minute later and then a minute
after that Tyrone Barnet scored a goal
and then it was 3-3 in the 94th minute
when with the last touch of the ball
Tom Elliott headed the ball into the
back of the net AFC Wimbledon win 4-3
having come back from a
three-nil deficit in the final ten
minutes of the game it was insanity yeah
and indeed it I want I watch the
highlights one of the nice things about
FA Cup games is that they actually get
some coverage and they and they put
together a highlight reel and we're
gonna put that on the patreon you can
watch it and it really is exciting just
to watch in like sort of five minute
digested version and and that final goal
was improbable like that is not an easy
Hey yeah I got a say by the way that I
feel terrible for kurzon Ashton I mean
that would have been the biggest win in
their history
yeah and it's devastating to lose that
way and my thoughts are certainly with
their fans but it does mean that AFC
Wimbledon made it to the third round
draw when they could have drawn games
against Manchester United or Chelsea or
Liverpool but in fact they drew arguably
an even more interesting matchup against
Sutton United Hank do you know why it's
interesting to be playing Sutton United
in the FA Cup I bet you're gonna believe
I don't it's because AFC Wimbledon's
first game back when they were in the
ninth tier was a pre-season friendly
against Sutton United the folks at
Sutton United opened up their Stadium to
Wimbledon supporters 4500 people came
they expected about 250 and that was AFC
Wimbledon's first game they lost four
nil but there was still a pitch invasion
at the end of the game and so now AFC
Wimbledon supporters get to go back to
that same field where AFC Wimbledon took
where where AFC Wimbledon played their
very first ever game as AFC Wimbledon so
it's a really exciting matchup and you
know theoretically winnable since Sutton
United now play in the fifth tier and
AFC Wimbledon are up in League One and
then who knows and then who knows
alright it's kind of the story of life
well the game with the the franchise
currently playing in Milton Keynes is
will have happened by the time this
podcast gets uploaded right correct
and so you will have to check the scores
for that because we don't know how it
went but we'll talk we hope we hope it
went well because they have to I'm gonna
play them very well and Milton Keynes is
all the way down at the bottom of the
table right now we I got a little bit of
Mars news for you I got to be honest I
haven't paying a huge amount of
attention but but I did get a tweet from
national to the National Geographic
Channel yesterday says at Hank green
the year is 2033 which is way too late
humans are developing property on
hashtag Mars
what crash course would you recommend
for those who wish to join them well
Chris do you think that Mars so this is
the National Geographic Channel which
they have a new show I don't know what
possibly called Mars and and I'm excited
to watch it but I haven't seen it yet
because I don't have cable in fact in
fact I I asked the National Geographic
Channel how a lowly cord cutter like me
could watch the series to which they did
not respond because it's an awkward
question
and yeah I I would say it's between
chemistry and astronomy but it's got to
be chemistry ultimately that's got to be
more helpful when you're actually on
Mars yeah that is that is true
you know you do learn about sort of like
you can in an astronomy course you might
end up learning some of the like xoxo
biology EXO geology that kind of stuff
but mostly you're not mostly you're not
learning that kind of stuff so yeah I
think chemistry is is that's what I said
that's what I told them and they they
said send us the syllabus we're in
hashtag Mars like half a minute I
complimented them on their good social
media strategy so I you know that got
that got 896 likes so some people saw
that and I'm excited about this series
I've heard that it's good and it is a it
is it is told in a very interesting way
where they have like real-life people
like Elon Musk and Neil deGrasse Tyson
talking about the mission in a
fictitious the fictitious mission as if
it is real so I'm excited to see it it
looks like it's got really great visual
effects and I love Mars I wish I had the
National Geographic Channel
and there probably is a way for me to
get it on iTunes or Amazon or something
but I'll be looking into that but right
now I'm a little busy to be watching the
TVs though there are lots of moments
when I could be could be watching TV
when it he sleeps a lot oh man i watch
TV so much when Henry was a little baby
because he didn't care yeah yeah
actually it seems like Orin would much
rather have me interacting with like if
he's like sitting on my lap and I'm
watching TV he's like dude dude I'm
right here what are we doing and I'm
like what's up and he's like oh now
we're doing something and I'm like oh
great you like to play you want to do
stuff okay oh that's very cute it was
such a pleasure to meet or and over
Thanksgiving I felt so lucky and so
happy to see you with such a beautiful
baby it brought me great joy Hank we
have to end our podcast now okay what
did we learn today oh gosh what did we
learn today we learned that I should
probably have a general practitioner of
some sort and don't yeah I'll say
we learned that you know whatever color
your hair is
according to Hank it's still brown it's
all brown everybody's got brown hair
knowing that diehard is a Christmas
movie but probably not the best
Christmas movie we learned that we live
on a planet called Earth but only
through a freak accident of linguistics
is it not called dirt and of course we
learned that broadly speaking if you
live in Alberta you should never leave
the house without bear spray I have to
say that even living in Indianapolis
where brown bears are relatively
uncommon for instance there's there's
never been a sighting of one outside of
a zoo I still feel like maybe I should
have bear spray on me at all times well
thank you for potting with me I missed
it so much oh it's very nice to have you
back thanks for coming back and not
choosing to spend the rest of your life
just hanging out with your kid which I
wouldn't blame you for doing but I'm
glad that you're back our podcast is
edited by nicholas jenkins rosianna
halse rojas helps out with questions
Victoria Bongiorno does all the social
media stuff and many other things as
well our theme music is by gunnarolla
you
email us at Hank and John at gmail.com
that's where you should email us to get
your question answered I apologize in
advance for all the questions we don't
answer Hank did I miss anything no I
don't think you did we've completely
forgot to tell you that your stuff in
the oven is burning and as they say in
our hometown oh my god it's burning
check on the stuff in the oven thank you
for listening and as we say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]